Barry asked Gary love to hear your
opinion on whether PR company or person
to be overseeing social media for a
business very great question and before
I even answer it I just want to thank
you for being a long time interact or
friend with me I like using the word fan
but I say it sometimes just slips barry
i've always enjoyed our conversations on
twitter over the last four years so
thrilled to have you on the show you
know i think i know where you're going
with this question which is the notion
of you know vaynermedia was built on
coming into companies and taking the
social media away from PR companies some
of the bigger PR companies in the world
right now have built out social media
departments and they've done a nice job
to varying degrees I wanted to answer
this question because I want to get
people around the psychology of the
difference between PR and social and why
I do think that of course there's people
look hundreds of people in this company
have worked in PR before so there's some
great things about PR being able to hang
a no-pressure the speed of it the
difference though is PR is very b2b when
you're a PR person and you're working
with a client the Yankees you're trying
to get them pressed in the New York
Times the New York Post ESPN you're
working directly with a human being
who's the gatekeeper to make a decision
when you're doing social you're gearing
with all the fans that it's much more
b2c so I don't have a problem if assoc
our person or company is doing the
social for a company or individual I
just want to make sure they have a
different gear in their brand
understanding brain that brand but that
was interesting slip up I just want to
make sure they have that gear to know
that they need to be looking at this as
a beat a singing versus the BB game that
is PR oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe